>> TUCKER CARLSON IS BROUGHT TO
YOU BY:.
>> Tucker: BELIEVE IT OR NOT THE
FULL RELEASE OF ALL FILES
RELATED TO THE JFK ASSASSINATION
WAS DELAYED AGAIN TO 2021.
THE PRESIDENT DELAYED THE
RELEASE IN THE NAME OF NATIONAL
SECURITY.
WHAT POSSIBLE NATIONAL SECURITY
INTEREST COULD BE SERVED AT THIS
POINT IN PROTECTING INFORMATION
ABOUT AN ASSASSINATION THAT
OCCURRED 55 YEARS AGO.
ROBERT KENNEDY JR. IS THE NEPHEW
OF THE SLAIN PRESIDENT AND JOINS
US.
I AM STRUCK HOW WEIRD THIS STORY
IS.
THE PRESIDENT SAID I WILL
RELEASE ALL OF THESE FILES.
HE WAS CONVINCED NOT TO RELEASE
THEM.
WHAT DO YOU IMAGINE THAT REASON
WAS?
>> WELL, I SHARE YOUR
MYSTIFICATION.
THE STUFF THAT IS DRIBBLING OUT,
IT IS INFORMATION THAT TENDS TO
CONNECT THE CIA TO THE SASS SAS
CONNECT THE CIA TO THE SASS SA
CONNECT THE CIA TO THE SASS  -
CONNECT THE CIA TO THE SASS  --
ASSASSINATION IN ONE WAY OR
OTHER.
IN NOVEMBER THEY LET A WATCH
OUT.
THAT SHOWED THAT CHARLES CABELL
THE MAYOR OF DALLAS WHEN MY
UNCLE WAS ASSASSINATED WAS A CIA
OPERATIVE AND HAD BEEN THAT
SINCE 1956.
THERE WAS INFORMATION ABOUT THE
AUTOMOBILE THAT SHOWED THE
WINDOW HAD BEEN REPLACED.
50 YEARS LATER PEOPLE SHOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION.
>> Tucker: DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
THE CIA WAS INVOLVED IN THE
ASSASSINATION OF YOUR UNCLE?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T THINK THAT POSSIBILITY
HAS BEEN ELIMINATED.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT WHEN JOHN KENNEDY WAS
KILLED, MY FATHER WAS ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
ONE OF THE DEFENSES OF THE
WARREN COMMISSION WAS BOBBY
KENNEDY WAS LIKE MUELLER OF THAT
ERA.
FOR 10 YEARS HE WAS
INVESTIGATING THE UNIONS AND THE
TEAMSTERS.
AND THE MOB.
SO, WHY WOULDN'T HE INVESTIGATE
IT?
BUT THE TRUTH IS, THE DAY HIS
BROTHER WAS KILLED HE LOST ALL
INVESTIGATIVE CAPACITY AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
30,000 FBI AGENCY WHO WORKED FOR
HIM SAID HE NEVER TALKED TO
HOOVER AGAIN AFTER MY UNCLE JACK
WAS KILLED.
HOOVER REPORT DIRECTLY TO
JOHNSON.
MY FATHER, WHO WAS [INAUDIBLE]
REALLY LOST CONTROL OF THE FBI
IN THE INVESTIGATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
>> Tucker: I FIND THE WHOLE
THING REMARKABLE.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES AND LATER A U.S.
SENATOR WOULD SUSPECT HIS OWN
CIA AND NOW THE DOCUMENTS ARE
STILL BEING WITH HELD BY THAT
SAME AGENCY.